the internet has a lot of thoughts about
keanu reeves and so does bridget
moynihan so is the star of the matrix
really as nice as he seems or are there
some skeletons in his closet moynihan's
revelations may surprise you when you've
worked in hollywood for as long as keanu
reeves has your reputation follows you
around everywhere and in the case of
movie stars the public gets to have an
opinion about an actor's on-the-job
behavior even if they don't have any
direct experience working with them in
the case of reeves his general
reputation seems to be that of a quiet
humble decent guy who happens to be one
of the most famous people on earth of
course it helps when he partakes in
delightful interviews where he answers
questions like a normal person and has
viral stories come out of the woodwork
about what a down-to-earth person he is
but is this reputation really accurate
every once in a while someone who's
worked with a star like reeves will give
us a tidbit about what the experience
was like bridget moynihan best known
today as one of the stars of the police
drama blue bloods worked with reeves on
both john wick in 2014 and the sequel
john wick chapter 2 in 2017. she played
his deceased wife helen wick whose final
act prior to her passing is gifting jon
a dog so that he won't be as alone after
she's gone as anyone who's seen the
movies can attest that dog plays a
pretty central role and during a 2014
interview she wasn't shy to share her
impressions of what reeves was like on
the set one hand is no stranger to
sharing the screen with some of the
biggest names in the business after all
she joins tom selleck and donnie
wahlberg on blue bloods with a resume
that also includes the likes of
serendipity and sex in the city it's
safe to say that moynihan has been
around the block a few times and
generally knows what to expect when
working with a-list stars during her
interview with aol moynihan was asked
about a bevy of her famous collaborators
over the years including al pacino and
of course keanu reeves when asked about
how her experience of working with
reeves on john wick was compared to what
she expected moynihan revealed he's very
quiet and very private i had always
heard that about him and he kind of
still was we had a really nice time we
were playing a couple that was in love
so that was really fun to do it sounds
like moynihan didn't get a chance to get
to know reeves too well despite playing
the assassins late wife and flashbacks
it makes sense given her role was killed
off pretty early in the film so she
probably didn't spend too much time
getting to know the legendary actor but
it also seems that her experience
working with reeves was a positive one
he is after all one of the co-stars that
caused one hand to declare during her
interview i had worked with the best
guys in the business when it comes to
actors one of the first things people
want to know is whether they're nice
there are so many horror stories of
celebrities acting like divas and
treating everyone they perceive as
beneath them like trash fortunately it
doesn't appear as though reeves falls
into this camp but several of his
co-stars have nothing but kind things to
say about him first there's his john
wick 3 partner halle berry who took to
instagram to gush over working with
reeves on the project meanwhile lance
reddick who's played sharon in all three
john wick movies today ted nothing but
nice things to say either the actor
describes what consummate professional
reeves was on set and even went so far
as to declare whenever i work with a big
movie star for the first time i keep my
guard up to protect my work from an ego
and if there's any big movie star who's
not that person it's keanu it appears
that if you're going to star alongside
any a-list celebrity in a major motion
picture you want it to be keanu reeves
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite celebrities are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
you